for the right family it's another
uncertain Christmas in cold country
Braxton Wright has been on strike from
Alabama's Warrior met coal mine for more
than 20 months we thought it would just
be a couple of weeks you know a couple
of maybe a month or two
as as greedy as this company was we
never thought that they would let it go
as long as it did Hayden a high school
teacher took out a loan for child care
they've given up Home Heating and
vacations and run-up credit card debt
but they're not giving up on the strike
workers are waking up and saying that
they're being taken advantage of that
when you see companies that are breaking
record profits record profits are stolen
wages
mining is in their blood three
generations for Braxton two for Hayden
with more workers joining unions across
the U.S Hayden says they are at the
Vanguard of a surging movement and I
think people are starting to say that
that they deserve better that they
deserve health care that they deserve to
be able to actually have a life not just
survive
this is truly a battle of Labor versus
Capital Warrior Met's largest owners or
Wall Street investment firms like
Fidelity Vanguard and BlackRock
BlackRock has called for the company to
resolve the labor dispute but the
company hasn't taken the advice of one
of its largest investors we asked
Warrior Matt for comment they declined
try to keep everybody as informed as
possible union workers meet every two
weeks to lift morale and get updates on
the strike these miners came nearly 3
000 kilometers from Wyoming that's a
long way to come for support yeah um
it's worth it though because I mean
who's to say who's next the picketer's
movements are strictly controlled here
in the anti-union South a judge is
limited them to eight picketers per site
state troopers escort non-union strike
Breakers I imagine there will be some
hard feelings
believe me the union agreed to pay and
benefit Cuts in 2016 to get the company
out of bankruptcy but struck when the
company refused to return to the old pay
scale even after record profits this
year the strikers survive on 800 checks
every two weeks from the United Mine
Workers strike fund on side jobs and
stubborn determination we're going to be
here to the end we're we're not going
anywhere we're not going to left that
company run over these guys
as Hayden once again hands out Christmas
gifts at a union food pantry funded by
donations Alabama's longest strike
approaches its two-year anniversary but
the miners insist another year longer
makes them another year stronger
John hendren Al Jazeera Brookwood
Alabama